is busy still involved
uh like we with with with your situation
yeah yeah yeah yeah he's he's still
involved he's still involved he's still
eating
yeah still getting his piece yeah yeah i
said i got three more i got three more
projects like you know what i'm saying
if they were boosting like people just
keep like just missing i'm just so be
so tired of just explaining but i have
uh like uh
just stated once before that you know
the situation is a custom situation like
i think you might have stated that here
before yeah like yeah
for real though it's like it's not like
people when people say
you could still honor something and not
be
because okay if i sit here and say that
the contract
boosie me and the booster negotiator he
said
i'm gonna i was gonna sign a deal with
empire i was gonna go get
you know saying a bigger bag like that
and i said
okay we had three more albums
left in the contract you know what i'm
saying so
he still get those three albums you know
what i'm saying you still get those
three hours man
like i said you still make money you
feel me i saw you just post like a
compilation of funny boozy moments
yeah like boosie's like the funniest
[ __ ] like quite possibly in
hip-hop history
yeah what is like the funniest [ __ ]
you've ever like witnessed in person
with busy
cause i mean it's just i've been around
him and like
i just feel like i feel like i know he
tried to do the reality tv show thing
and i thought it should have been a lot
bigger
yeah but like he is probably the most
entertaining person yeah
now you know you don't even really have
no favorite
favorite moment like you know what i'm
saying boost is just funny and like
people
like booster really like you know what
i'm saying a real brother i just hate
when people be like
just taking my words and we like for
real though
people know so much less people know so
little about deals and stuff like that
that i just the easiest thing for me to
say is
yeah i'm still signing a booster you
feel me of course because if i break it
down
for real you people people the wrong
person's not even gonna understand what
i'm even saying you're feeling they just
gonna be like oh he's trying to say he
ain't signing a boost yeah
i'm still inside a booster like i said
he's always better however
when you when you find out he got shot
man because that was rough man
right after that so i knew he was good
like before the world you know saying
like i said i'm
close to boosters so when you see [ __ ]
like that happen because we've seen a
lot of people get hit like recently you
know benny the butcher
and yeah you know a lot of people have
you know fortunately
i feel like you know jim jones said this
recently that being an artist is one of
the most dangerous jobs in the world
does that kind of you know i feel like
you
you have to kind of take notes and like
move differently right yeah
i feel like i'm more like i ain't really
never thought i'd have to be
you know saying roller like i'm rolling
but you know it just come with it man
cuz
some people just don't you know some
people don't
think logical you feel me they just
especially when they see your artist
it's like a
a button just click you just you know
what i'm saying
so you just got to be protected man yeah
they can't watch it you can't watch
everything
all the time you know